On the 14th of April, 1912, with over 2200 people on board,...
...the Titanic was on its maiden voyage across the Atlantic to New York.
She was the biggest passenger steam ship of the day.
In fact, the largest moving object ever created by mankind.
Incredible luxury combined with great speed,...
...Titanic incorporated two major safety factors in her design.
The first was a double bottom hull,...
...which protects the ship if it hits an underwater obstruction.
The second were her compartments,...
...which subdivide the interior of the ship to stop the spread of flooding.
These and other design features gave the ship a reputation for safety...
...and inspired great confidence in her passengers and crew.
Some even called her unsinkable.